CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN ARCHULETA
ATKINS BABIES BELL LARGEST
BRADFORD CABALLERO CHIANG ALLEY
DODD THE RAZA GALGIANI GONZALEZ
GROVE HERTZBERG HELLO HUESO
HURTADO JACKSON JONES LEYVA
MCGUIRE MELENDEZ MITCHELL
MONNING MORLOCK MORALE NIELSEN
PAN PORTANTINO ROTH. RUBIO
SKINNER WHY CASKEY WIENER WILK.
THANK YOU SO MUCH BETTER
SECRETARY MADAM SECRETARY HAS
ESTABLISHED A QUORUM A QUORUM
IS PRESENT MEMBERS TODAY WE
HAVE SENATORS GLAZER STERN IN
NUMBER GLAZER STERN IN NUMBER
PARTICIPATING REMOTELY WE'RE
GONNA WELCOME THOSE SENATORS AT
TO SESSION THE SENATORS WILL
PARTICIPATE IN DISCUSSION AND
DEBATE BUT WILL NOT BE
PARTICIPATING IN THE QUORUM
CALL ORDER VOTE ON MEASURES.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
WOULD ALL MEMBERS IN OUR GUESTS
BEYOND THE RAIL AND IN THE
GALLERY PLEASE RISE WILL BE
LEADING PRAYER THIS MORNING BY
SENATOR JACKSON AFTER WHICH
PLEASE REMAIN STANDING WE'RE
GONNA BE LED IN THE PLEDGE
ALLEGIANCE TO THE FLAG BY
SENATOR. CENTER THANK YOU
MISTER. CALL FROM. MY HEART IN
MY MOUTH PLEASE JOIN ME. THREE
GOD WE NEED TO IN UNEXPECTED
PLACES TRACES OF YOUR GRACE ARE
STREWN ALL OVER OUR SCHEDULE
PUCKERED LIVES WE ASK TO BE
STIRRED TOWARD SOUL SATISFYING
RESULTS AS WE DESIRE TO SERVE
Q. AND NEIGHBOR AND EVEN OUR
ENEMY. EASE US INTO BEING GOOD
SAMARITANS TO EACH OTHER TO THE
OUTCAST AND REJECTED ONES AND
TO THOSE WHOSE FEAR SOMETIMES
MAKES THEM OBNOXIOUS. MAKE US
BOLD TO CALL OTHERS TO
ACCOUNTABILITY EVEN AS WE MODEL
HUMILITY TO THE ARROGANT MERCY
TO THE SELF RIGHTEOUS
COMPASSION TO THE IN DIFFERENT.
OH GOD OF MANY SURPRISES MAKE
US GLAD OF HEART FOR EACH DAY'S
OPPORTUNITIES TO BRING OUR
IMAGINATIONAND CREATIVITY TO
THE DISTURBANCES THAT
THREATENED TO DISCOURAGE US. WE
WILL CONTINUE TO BELIEVE IN THE
IMPOSSIBLE- IN. FIVE YES. IF.
FOR ALL. THANK YOU CENTER
JACKSON THANK YOU SENATOR BATES.
SENATORS ARE NOT GONNA BE
MOVING NINE IN OUR FILE TODAY
UNDER PRIVILEGES OF THE FLOOR
THERE ARE NONE. MESSAGES OF THE
GOVERNOR WILL BE DEEMED READ.
MESSAGES FROM THE ASSEMBLY WILL
BE DEEMED READ REPORTS OF
COMMITTEES WILL BE DEEMED READ
AND AMENDMENTS ADOPTED LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN WE'RE NOW MOVING
ON TO MOTIONS RESOLUTIONS AND
NOTICES. GOOD MORNING CENTER
MELENDEZ FOR WHAT PURPOSE YOU
RISE. GOOD MORNING MR PRESIDENT
I RISE TO MAKE A MOTION
PURSUANT TO SENATE RULE TWENTY
EIGHT TO WITHDRAW AS HERE
NINETY THREE FROM THE RULES
COMMITTEE AND BROUGHT TO THE
SENATE FLOOR. SO THAT THE
SENATE CAN HAVE A FULL AND
VIGOROUS DEBATE ABOUT THE
MERITS OF THE GOVERNOR'S STATE
OF EMERGENCY ORDER. THANK YOU
SO MUCH THIS LETTER IS SENATOR
MELINDA CENTER JONES FOR WHAT
PURPOSE YOU RISE. I RISE IN
SUPPORT OF THE MOTION THE
LANGUAGE CONTAINED IN THIS
RESOLUTION IS VERY IMPORTANT
DIALOGUE. THAT ALL OF US ON
THIS FLOOR SHOULD BE
CONSIDERING AND TALKING ABOUT.
AND I BELIEVE THAT OUR
CONSTITUENTS ARE EXPECTING US.
TO DO OUR JOB IS LEGISLATORS IN
INTERACTING WITH THE GOVERNOR'S
OFFICE AND I ASKED FOR AN AYE
VOTE. THANK YOU SO MUCH SOONER
JONES IS ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE
MR MAJORITY LEADER FOR WHAT
PURPOSE. MISTER PRESIDENT DIED
AS A PROCEDURAL MODE MATTER ASK
FOR NO VOTE IN THIS MATTER
THANK YOU SO MUCH THE MAJORITY
LEADER IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE
THE MAJORITY LEADERS ASKING FOR
A NO VOTE SENATOR JONES IS
ASKING FOR AN AYE VOTE ON THE
WITHDRAWAL. MADAM SECRETARY CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN
ARCHULETA NO ATKINS. NO BAY. HI
BELL NO FOR JUST HI BRADFORD NO
CABALLERO NO CHIANG HI DOLLY I
DON. NO THE RAZA NO GALGIANI NO
GONZALEZ NO GROWTH. HI
HERTZBERG. NO HILL NO WAY SO.
NO HER TADO NO JACKSON NO JONES
I LEYVA. LEYVA NO MCGUIRE YOU
KNOW MELENDEZ AYE MITCHELL. NO
MONEYNO MORE LAW I MORALE I
NIELSEN. HI PAN NO PORTANTINO
NO ROTH. NO RUBIO NO SKINNER.
WHITE HOUSE SKI. NO WIENER NO
WELL HI MADAM SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ABSENT MEMBERS
ONCE. ALLEN NOSKINNER. HIS
ELEVEN NOS TWENTY FIVE THE
MOTION FAILS. THERE IS A GERMAN
WE'RE GOING TO RECOGNIZE CENTER
DOLLY CENTER DOLLY FOR WHAT
PURPOSE YOU RISE THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT- PRASANTH TO RULE
TWENTY EIGHT I MAKING A MOTION
TO WITHDRAW AB THIRTEEN EIGHTY
FOUR FROM THE SENATE JUDICIARY
COMMITTEE TO THE SENATE FLOOR
SO WE CAN HAVE A FULL SENATE-
AND VIGOROUS DEBATE ABOUT THE
MERITSOF COBIT LIABILITY
PROTECTIONS FOR SCHOOL
DISTRICTS. ACROSS THE STATE AND
ESPECIALLY RULE WANTS TO BE
ABLE TO RE OPEN IMMEDIATELY
HIRED AN AYE VOTE ON THIS
MOTION THANK YOU SO MUCH CENTER
DOLLY WE'RE GOING TO RECOGNIZE
SENATOR JONES SOONER JONES
WROTE THIS THANK YOU MR
PRESIDENT IS IN SUPPORT OF THE
MOTION TO WITHDRAW. ASSEMBLY
BILL BY CALLING US IN THE
MEMBER PORTAL WHO MOST OF US
RECOGNIZED AS ONE OF OUR
LEADING EXPERTS EDUCATION
OTHERS IS IMPORTANT AND
IMPORTANT CONVERSE FOR TO HELP
ON THE FLOOR AS FOR AN AYE VOTE
A MOTION TO WITHDRAW CENTER
JONES ENERGY IS ASKING FOR A
VOTE BUT DROPPED MISTER ROGERS
COOPER. THANK YOU FOR MUCH MR
PRESIDENT TO ASK FOR A NO OF
FOR SHE MOTION THANK YOU VERY
MUCH SENATORS THREE CARE JONES
SYNERGY. IS FOR IT I VOTE THE
MID LEADER THE MAJORITY LEADER
IS ASKING FOR A NO VOTE ON THE
MOTION. MADAM SECRETARY CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN.
ARCHULETA NO ATKINS NO BATES. I
FELL NO PORGES I BRADFORD NO
CABALLERO NO CHIANG THE FIVE
DALLY. FIVE DOT. NO TORONTO. NO
GALGIANI NO GONZALEZ NO GROWTH.
HI HERTZBERG NO HILL NO WAY SO.
HURTADO NO JACKSON. NO JONES
FIVE LEYVA NO MCGUIRE. NO
MELENDEZ AYE MITCHELL. NO MONEY
NO MORE LOCK I RURAL. FIVE
NIELSEN I CAN NO PORTANTINO.
PORTANTINO NO ROTH. NO RUBIO.
NO SKINNER WHITE HOUSE SKI. NO
WIENER. NO WELL. HI MADAM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE CALL
THE ABSENT MEMBERS ALLEN. ALLEN.
YEAH ALLEN. NOW HUESO NO
SKINNER. HIS ELEVEN DOES TWENTY
FIVE. THE MOTION TO A DRIVE
FAILS. THANK YOU SENATORS.
MEMBERS ARE NOT GONNA BE MOVING
ON TO THE CONSIDERATION OF THE
DAILY FILE. OKAY THANK YOU SO
MUCH I CENTER DOLLARS FOR WHAT
PURPOSE YOU RISE BUT YOU MISTER
PRESIDENT APPROPRIATE TIME I
WOULD LIKE TO BE RECOGNIZED TO
SPEAK ON CONDITION OF THE FILE.
THANK YOU SO MUCH YOU'RE GONNA
COME BACK. PROBABLY NOT IN WILL
WORK WITH YOU IN REGARDS THE
FOR EVERY TIME FOR CONDITION
THE FILE APPRECIATE YOU RISING
FOR THAT. LADIES AND GENTLEMEN
WE'RE NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
A SECOND READING FILE. ITEM
SECRETARY CAN YOU PLEASE READ.
ASSEMBLY BILL THIRTY SEVENTY
WITH AMENDMENTS OF THIRTY
THIRTY WITH AMENDMENTS. THIRTY
TO FOURTEEN WITH AMENDMENTS.
WITH AMENDMENTS ASSEMBLY BILL
EIGHT NINETY WITH AMENDMENTS
AND ASSEMBLY BILL SEVENTEEN TEN
WITH AMENDMENTS. THANK YOU VERY
MUCH OF MADAM SECRETARY LADIES
AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO
GOVERNOR'S APPOINTMENTS. WE
HAVE THREE ITEMS ARE GOING TO
BE IN FRONT OF US TODAY CENTER
WILL BE PREPARED TO PRESENT ALL
THREE. BURKE IF YOU COULD
PLEASE REPORT AN ITEM NUMBER
SEVEN. THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT
MEMBERS FILE ITEM NUMBER SEVEN
IS A CONFIRMATION OF- THOMAS
SAID STEIN FOR REAPPOINTMENT
EVOLUTION ESCOBAR CARILLO. AND
DR ELMA SALAZAR FOR APPOINTMENT
TO THE CALIFORNIA COMMUNITY
COLLEGES BOARD OF GOVERNORS. MR
OF SCIENCE CURRENTLY THE
BOARD'S CHAIR PRIOR TO HIS
RETIREMENT HE WAS VICE
PRESIDENT FOR PUBLIC AFFAIRS A
BLUE SHIELD OF CALIFORNIA. MISA
YEAH- IS A DRIP IMMIGRATION FOR
THE BE CONFINED. AND DOCTORS
SARS EXECUTIVE VICE PRESIDENT
OF THE LOS ANGELES AREA CHAMBER
OF COMMERCE. HERE PROVED BY THE
RULES ON THE TO THE NIGHT OF
JULY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. THANK YOU YOU'RE
WELCOME IS THERE DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. THANK YOU.
FIRST PRESENT I RISE SUPPORT OF
MR APPS DEAN WHO I WORKED WITH
IN WASHINGTON DC. LONG TIME AGO
SEVENTY SEVEN I THINK IN THE
CARTER ADMINISTRATION AND
WATCHED HIM RISE TO WORKING IN
THE COUNTY OF LOS ANGELES AND
BACK IN THE CLINTON
ADMINISTRATION YEARS LATER. AND
HE IS JUST A WELL EXTRAORDINARY
PERSON WORKS EXTREMELY HARD AT
THIS JOB. AND I JUST WANT TO
STAND TALL FOR HIM AND- AND
EXPRESSED MY STRONG SUPPORT
THANK YOU MR MAJORITY LEADER.
MEMBERS FINAL DISCUSSION OR
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. LAST CALL
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE ON THE
FLOOR. HEARING SEEN MINUTES CAN
YOU PLEASE CALL THE- ALLEN. I
ARCHULETA I ATKINS AYE BATES I
TELL I FORGES HI BRADFORD. I
HAVE ITEM I CHIANG. I DALY. I
DON. HI TORONTO FIVE GALGIANI I
GONZALEZ. I GROW. I HERTZBERG
HI HILL AYE HUESO. HI HER TADO
FIVE JACKSON. HI JONES. FIVE
LEYVA. FIVE MCGUIRE HI FIVE
MELENDEZ AYE MITCHELL. HI ONE
NINE FIVE WARLOCK I RURAL. I
NIELSEN. I PAN FIVE PORTANTINO.
FIVE ROTH FIVE RUBIO HI SKINNER.
BY CASKEY FIVE WIENER HI WILK I.
FIVE THIRTY SIX NO ZERO THREE
APPOINTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED.
LADIES AND GENTLEMEN THE SENATE
RIGHT NOW MOVES ON TO I NUMBER
A CENTER WILL PREPARE TO
PRESENT. THANK YOU MISS PRESS.
NUMBER FOR ME DEBRECENI TO THE
BORDER HEARINGS MISALNYA ITSELF
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER AND
SPENT TWENTY SIX YEARS.
DEPARTMENT OF CORRECTIONS THE
WREATH OF REHABILITATION AS A
PAROLE AGENT AND ADMINISTRATOR
SHE ALSO SERVED AS A LICENSED
CLINICAL SOCIAL WORKER AT THE
CENTER SOLANO MEDICAL CENTER
PRIOR TO THIS APPOINTMENT I
RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR AN AYE
VOTE. SENATORS IS OUR
DISCUSSION OR DEBATE BEFORE.
FINAL CALL DISCUSSION OR DEBATE
ON THE FLOOR. HEARING SEE NONE
BETTER SECTOR CAN YOU PLEASE
CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN FIVE
ARCHULETA BY ATKINS FIVE FACE
NOTE FELL FIVE FOR JUST.
BRADFORD FIVE BY ADAM I CHIANG.
DALLY NO DODD. FIVE THE RAZA I
GALGIANI. FIVE GONZALEZ I
GROWTH. NO HERTZBERG. I HILL
AYE HUESO. FIVE HER TADO I
JACKSON. FIVE JONES NO LEYVA I
MCGUIRE HI MELINDA'S NO
MITCHELL HI HI MY NAME. I
MORLOCK NO MORALE. NO NIELSEN.
NO PAN I PORTANTINO. I ROTH
FIVE RUBIO. HI SKINNER. WHITE
HOUSE SKI FIVE WIENER AYE WILK
I. FIVE TWENTY SIX NO STATE THE
APPOINTMENT IS CONFIRMED. WE'RE
NOT GONNA BE MOVING ON TO OUR
FINAL APPOINTMENT IN FRONT OF
THE SENATE HERE TODAY CENTER
WOKE PLEASE PROCEED THANK YOU
MISTER PRESENT A MEMBERS FOR
YOUR CONSIDERATION IS FILE ITEM
NUMBER NINE. WHICH IS THE-
ORDER PAROLE HEARINGS. PRIOR TO
THIS APPOINTMENT MISS WHICH
HERE SPENT TWENTY EIGHT YEARS
WITHL. A. COUNTY SHERIFF'S
OFFICE MR IN WAS A DEPUTY
DISTRICT ATTORNEY AND ALSO
SERVED AS DEPUTY PAROLE
COMMISSIONER. BOTH APPOINTEES
WERE APPROVED BY THE RULES
COMMITTEE ON THE TWENTY NINTH
TO JULY I RESPECTFULLY ASK FOR
YOUR I. BOATS. SENATORS IS
THERE ANY QUESTION OR DEBATE ON
THE FLOOR. FINAL CALL SURE
DEBATE ON THE FLOOR. KAREN C.
NINE MEN OF SECTOR CAN YOU
PLEASE CALL THE ROLL. ALLEN AYE
ARCHULETA. AYE ATKINS I BATES I
FELT I PORGES. BRADFORD FIVE
CABALLERO I CHIANG. DALLY FIVE
DODD. FIVE TORONTO FIVE
GALGIANI FIVE GONZALEZ. I
GROWTH. HI HERTZBERG. HI HILL I
HUESO ONE FIVE FOR TADO I
JACKSON. FIVE JONES FIVE LEYVA.
FIVE MCGUIRE I MELENDEZ AYE
MITCHELL I MONEY. I MORE LOOK
FIVE MORALE. FIVE NIELSEN. I
CAN HI PORTANTINO. FIVE ROTH
FIVE RUBIO. FIVE SKINNER. WHITE
HOUSE SKI FIVE WIENER AYE WILK
HI. I IS THIRTY FOUR NO ZERO
THE APPOINTMENTS ARE CONFIRMED.
THANK YOU MADAM SECRETARY THANK
YOU CENTER WILL FOR NOW TO BE
MOVING ON TO COMMITTEE
ANNOUNCEMENTS WE HAVE THREE
ANNOUNCEMENTS THAT START WITH
THE JUDICIARY CENTER JACKSON
THANK YOU MR PRESIDENT UPON
COMPLETION OF OUR- SESSION
TODAY OR ARE FLOOR SESSION
TODAY AND AFTER CLEANING OF
THE- FACILITY THE SENATE
COMMITTEE ON THE JUDICIARY WILL
BE MEETING. THANK YOU WHICH IS
ACCENT THE THANK YOU CENTER
BRADFORD. YES BONTA GERMAN OF
SESSION WE WILL BE CONDUCTING A
BANKING AND FINANCE- HEARING
TODAY AS WELL. THANK YOU SO
MUCH THIS. THANK YOU WILL BE IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE FORTY TWO OR
THREE VERSIONS ARKHAM FORTY TO
THIRTY THANK YOU SO MUCH.
THAT'S RECOGNIZE CENTER
PORTANTINO AND APPROPRIATIONS.
YES PRESIDENT MEMBER YOU
PROGRESS COMMITTEE WILL BE
MEETING TODAY AT ONE O'CLOCK IN
FORTY TWO OH THREE THANK YOU SO
MUCH APPROPRIATIONS IN ROOM
FORTY TWO THREE AT ONE PM THANK
YOU. MISTER CHAIR. BASIN
GENTLEMAN THE SENATE IF THERE'S
NO OTHER BUSINESS CENTER ATKINS
THE DESK IS CLEAR. WE'RE GONNA
NOW I COULD NOT A SENATOR DOLLY
AND CONDITION OF THE FILE
CENTER DOLLY CONDITION THE FILE
THE FLOOR IS YOURS SIR. THANK
YOU MR PRESIDENT MEMBERS. I'M
HOPING I'M GONNA DO THIS UP
PROPERLY I DID SPEAK WITH THE
SENATE TO FOLKS ABOUT HOW TO GO
ABOUT THIS- AS WELL SURE WHAT'S
HAPPENING IN MY DISTRICT AS YOU
MANY OF YOU KNOW. SCHOOL HAS
OPENED- WOULD NORMAL SCENARIO
AS OF LAST WEEK. AND MANY OF
OUR SCHOOL BOARDS WOULD OPEN
BUT THERE'S A LIABILITY FOR
ALONG WITH THEIR RULES- AND SO
IF YOU'RE STILL PARENT THE
CHILD. AND YOU. SEND YOUR CHILD
TO THE SCHOOL THAT COULD OPEN
WITH THE PROPER SOCIAL
DISTANCING IN THE LIGHT- THAT
WOULD ALLOW YOU TO BE ABLE TO
ACTUALLY GO TO WORK AND SO
THERE ARE. THAT ARE IN THE
COMMITTEES THAT WHAT DO YOU
LEAVE EIGHT THESE PRO. AND
THERE ARE MANY MEMBERS OF THIS
HOUSE WHO ARE. A JOINT AUTHORS
AND CO AUTHORS OF THESE
POLICIES AND I WOULD JUST LIKE
TO SEE THOSE COME MORE QUICKLY-
SO THAT THE STATE. AN GET BACK
TO ANORMAL WAY OF LIFE. M.
YOUR WEEKS AND SO. THESE PEOPLE
SEE TERM. I DEBATE DIDN'T THE
LIGHTS ARE GOING TO BE REALLY
THOU. OF STUDENTS AND PARENTS-
PUT IN A SITUATION THAT IS VERY
DIFFICULT. AND SO- THAT'S WHY
RISE TO SH WHAT'S HAPPENING IN
MY DISTRICT AND I'M ASSUMING.
THOSE THINGS ARE HAPPENING IN
YOURS AS WELL THANK YOU. THANK
YOU CENTER DOLLY MADAM CHAIRMAN
THE DESK IS CLEAR. MISTER
PRESIDENT THANK YOU VERY MUCH
COLLEAGUES- THANK YOU FOR A
LONG AND PRODUCTIVE WORK WEEK
OUR NEXT FLOOR SESSION WILL BE
MONDAY AUGUST SEVENTEENTH
TWENTY AT TWO PM- PLEASE HAVE A
WONDERFUL WEEKEND AND I LOOK
FORWARD TO SEEING YOU ON MONDAY
AND THAT THERE'S WORK TOMORROW
AND I BUDGET COMMITTEE ON
SATURDAY- HEARING. SATURDAY BUT
A WONDERFUL WEEKEND THANK YOU
SEE MONDAY AT TWO PM THANK YOU
MUCH BETTER PRO TEM SENATORS
THE SENATE WILL BE IN RECESS
UNTIL ALL LEGISLATIVE PROCESS
IS PRECEDED AT THE DESK
RECONVENE ON. IT HAVE A ONE CAN
WAS TO